irrespective of whether you consider
Jesus a popular latina and preacher or
the Son of God there's a very hard thing
about his views on love he not only
spoke a great deal about love he went on
to advocate that we should love some
highly surprising people at one point
described in Chapter 7 of Luke's Gospel
Jesus goes to a dinner party and a local
prostitute turns up much to the disgust
of his hosts but Jesus is friendly and
sweet and defends her against everyone
else's criticism in a way that shocks
the other guests he insists that at
heart she is a very good person there's
another story in Matthew chapter 8 where
Jesus is approached by a man with
leprosy he's in a disgusting state but
Jesus isn't shocked reaches out his hand
and touches the man
despite the horrendous appearance here
is someone in Jesus's eyes entirely
deserving of closeness and kindness in a
similar vein at other times Jesus
conspicuously argues that tax collectors
thieves and adulterers and never to be
thought of as outside the circle of love
many centuries after his death the
foremost medieval thinker Thomas Aquinas
defined what Jesus was getting at in
this way of talking about love
he wrote the person who truly
understands love could love anyone in
other words true love isn't specific in
its target it doesn't fixate on
particular qualities it's open to all of
humanity even and in a way especially
it's less appealing examples today this
can sound like a deeply strange notion
of what love is for our background ideas
about love
tend to be closely tied to a dramatic
experience that of falling in love that
is finding one very specific person
immensely attractive exciting and free
of any failings or drawbacks love is we
feel a response to an overt perfection
of another person yet via some
admittedly extreme examples a very
important aspect of love is being pushed
to the fore in Jesus's vision and we
don't have to be Christian that is
we don't have to believe there's an
afterlife or that Jesus was born to a
virgin to benefit from it
at the heart of this kind of love is an
effort to see beyond the outwardly
unappealing surface of another human in
search of the tender interesting scared
and vulnerable person inside what we
know as the work of love is the
emotional imaginative labor that's
required to peer behind an off-putting
facade our minds tend fiercely to resist
such a move they follow well-worn groups
that feel familiar and justified for
instance if someone's hurt us we
naturally see them as horrible the
thought they might themselves be hurting
inside feels weird if a person looks odd
we find it extremely difficult to
recognize there might well be many
touching things about them deep down if
unpleasant events happen in someone's
life if they keep losing that job or
acquire a habit of drinking too much or
even develop cancer we somehow tempted
to hold them responsible for their
misfortunes it takes a deliberate taxing
effort of the mind to move ourselves off
these deeply established responses to do
so might mean taking an unappealing
looking person and trying to imagine
them say as a young child
unselfconsciously
playing on their bedroom floor we might
try to picture their mother not long
after their birth holding them in her
arms overcome by a passionate love for
this new little life or perhaps drunk
and passed out ignoring that desperate
crimes we might see a furious person in
a restaurant violently complaining that
the tomato sauce is on the wrong side of
their plate but rather than condemn and
feel superior we might try to construct
a story of how this individual had come
to be so impossible and how powerless
they must feel in a world where
something and obviously not what they're
ostensibly complaining about has
frustrated them to the core the more
energy we expend in thinking like this
the more we stand to discover a very
surprising truth that we could
potentially see the loveable sides of
pretty much
anyone that doesn't mean we should give
up on all criteria when searching for a
partner it's a way of saying that the
nicest person will eventually require us
to look at them with imagination as we
try to negotiate around some of their
gravely dispiriting sides and of course
the traffic won't ever be all just one
way we too are deeply challenging to be
around and therefore stand in need of a
constantly imaginative tender gaze to
rescue us from being dismissed as merely
another everyday monster
you